we'll be joined now from north london by
the attorney general sweller braverman
and hello nice to talk to you today what
is going on in parliament
well i i mean this is obviously uh an
appalling report and uh completely
unacceptable behavior if proven to be
true i haven't met any one in parliament
or in government over the last 24 hours
who hasn't expressed just total shock
actually
and disappointment
you say if proven to be true do you
think it may not be
uh listen i'm i'm a law office i i never
prejudged the outcome of any uh due
process but uh you know i'm very glad
there is a rigorous process that's in
place now i'm very glad that the chief
whip has referred the matter to the
independent complaints and grievance
scheme
that is a robust and impartial process
which will carry out an investigation
and i hope will apply if proven as i say
apply uh the appropriate sanction
and as far as you're aware has a name
been given to that uh independent
complaints and grievance scheme for them
to take action and start an
investigation
well i'm not aware of the name
of the individual in question um and i'm
not aware either actually who the
complainants are i've just i wasn't in
the meeting where the concerns were
raised i've heard about it through
through other colleagues so to speak um
so uh uh you know the complaint has been
referred uh to the uh the grievance
scheme there'll now be an initial uh
investigation and uh a certain criteria
will apply uh and then there'll be a
more uh fuller investigation if
appropriate and as i say a ruling and a
sanction is appropriate
i mean in terms of the number of mps are
also being investigated for
inappropriate behavior 56 i think i
think it is is the independent
complaints and grievance scheme also
dealing with all of that because it
seems like they're rather busy
well you're right there's been a report
of 56 uh members of parliament currently
under investigation so you've got to be
careful they haven't been proven yet but
under investigation and and let's be
clear even one uh complaint and and one
proven complaint is is too many um i
mean i'm obviously disappointed by that
number um there it is a minority uh of
uh male mps or mps in general and
speaking from my own experience i've
been an mp for seven years i've been in
politics for 20 years um i i haven't
experienced
any kind of harassment or sexual
misconduct and actually uh all of my
interactions with male counterparts have
been positive the men that i've worked
with have been respectful and courteous
so i don't think this is a pervasive to
parliament or pervasive to politics i
think this is actually more reflective
of a broader social issue we have in in
our broader culture but of course we
have a minority of people who have who
are subject to complaints i think that
probably reflects many if not all
workplaces and very disappointed by that
there will be a right the proper process
that is applied um but i actually think
we need to be asking ourselves more
profound questions as to why as a
society we're getting to the position
where it's becoming normal for some
people to watch pornography in the
workplace why is it so accessible um and
actually those are some of the broader
questions and more profound questions we
need to start talking about
you talk about some people and mps in
general but let's be clear are there any
suggestions that there are any
allegations that female mps have looked
at pornography or the female mps i don't
think so yeah i'm very clear about it it
is men uh generally who are uh guilty of
this kind of thing i don't think there's
a i don't know uh who the complaints are
made against uh but i very much suspect
they are largely against men when it
comes to sexual misconduct issues do you
think there should be a police
investigation
well i mean at this stage we have a this
is a workplace misconduct issue there's
a a code of conduct that all members of
parliament subscribe to
and it's against that code of conduct
that this mp will be judged it will be
overseen by the parliamentary
commissioner for standards and there
will be um a
as i say a sanction a sanction
appropriate to the uh proven uh if you
know um wrongdoing and that could be a
range of things i mean it could you know
i i think this is very serious
potentially and i think it should
potentially carry one of those serious
sanctions but sexual misconduct
carries uh covers a range of uh
of issues from harassment to sexual
assault to non-consensual uh behavior
voyeurism stalking there's a broad range
which comes under the umbrella of sexual
misconduct but i think that watching
porn in the chamber is absolutely
outrageous and should definitely come
under sexual misconduct
do you think whatever sanctions there
are enough because we've heard about
people potentially losing the whip but
shouldn't it be pretty cut and dry but
anybody who's actually done this during
work time especially in somewhere like
the chamber where it's actually publicly
viewable it is not suitable to remain in
their job
there are many possible sanctions and
they go up to suspension or even
expulsion from the house of commons and
uh you know as i said i don't want to
prejudge any uh decision that should be
made by an independent body but yes the
most serious sanction could potentially
apply in this case